the series is set in a dystopian City
called New London where Humanity has
evolved significantly and drastically
human beings no longer reproduce and
each fetus is created in a lab and
designated as a particular cast the five
castes are alpha beta Gamma Delta and
Epsilon alphas and betas are designated
the smartest and most privileged while
the lower castes like deltas and
epsilons are cloned and given
undesirable jobs once born the children
are all conditioned using electric prods
to stick to their designation they
should just give them all ps5s and
Netflix they'll stay in their Lane the
place is ultra futuristic there is no
crime or violence everyone leads a
healthy life and most importantly people
are treated with respect but with that
being said there are also Three Strange
rules implemented in New London because
reproduction is now the responsibility
of the state there is no longer a
concept of a family of a father or
mother no one is allowed to marry or be
in a monogamous relationship and having
privacy is strictly prohibited the
entire population of New London is
implanted with a bionic eye chip known
as Indra which is supposedly responsible
for maintaining transparency in the city
because of the chip each and every
inhabitant can see what others are doing
whether it be at work or at the toilet
the only way to go private is by taking
your eye chip out but this is generally
considered immoral also anyone who feels
even a hint of any negative emotion such
as sadness fear or anxiety needs simply
to take a happy pill called soma in a
day one might even eat 100 Somas thanks
to this pill New London Prides itself as
being the only city in the world where
no one is sad at the start we are
introduced to one of our protagonists
lanina Crown a beta plus inhabitant who
works as a microbiologist for the New
London government one day while she is
busy with work she is suddenly summoned
to an alpha plus Bernard's office since
one has to obey their seniors lanina
quickly heads there and on the way we
get a glimpse of the beautiful and
futuristic city when she arrives Bernard
warns her that she's breaking rules and
being selfish by exclusively sleeping
with another Alpha plus named Henry when
lalina denies this Bernard simply pulls
up a projection showing all 22 times she
and Henry had slept together in the past
few weeks demonstrating that no privacy
rules before leaving Bernard suggests
lanina be more careful next time and
answer a Soma pill to relax next we are
shown an advertisement of the Savage
Lance The Savage lands is considered a
theme park to the members of New London
it is the place where Natural Born
humans who refused to sign up to the New
London project 200 years ago continue to
live people in The Savage lands have
relationships get married and even have
children that said they're all extremely
poor and live in Rundown communities far
away from the glitz and glamor of New
London people out here don't take Soma
they just try to survive but they also
have more freedom but for the people of
New London the Savages are just a means
of amusement just like a zoo they even
perform different derogatory tricks to
amuse their Advanced counter Parts
meanwhile in New London Bernard is
ordered by the director of New London Ed
to go and have a look at an accident on
reaching there Bernard finds a large
crowd gathered around a corpse who is
apparently fallen from a tall building
the deceased is identified as an Epsilon
cleaner strangely another Epsilon c-jack
60 is seen grieving his friend as if he
has developed some feelings but before
anyone says a word Bernard distributes
Soma to the entire crowd to cope with
their Trauma from seeing the body and
sends them all away everyone wants to
believe he just fell from one of the
balconies but Bernard starts to wonder
if something more Sinister occurred if
he did not fall could he have jumped
considering everyone is supposed to be
happy all the time the idea of committed
the unthinkable is unheard of following
this he heads to his good friend Wilma
Watson who is also the head of
pleasurable parties in the city she is
responsible for arranging erotic night
parties where the inhabitants of New
London can come and relieve themselves
Bernard tells her about the deceased
Epsilon and how he may have committed
the unthinkable but Watson Buffs his
claims claiming that it's impossible she
also asserts that even if an Epsilon
starts thinking on their own the Soma
pill will never allow them to become
depressed and commit such an act the
series then cuts to the Savage lands
where we are introduced to our other
protagonist John he is a hard-working
and honest man who works as the props
manager for a Savage circus however he
is often bullied by his boss and other
colleagues for being weak he lives with
his alcoholic but caring mother Linda
who stays at home all day waiting for
her estranged husband to return Jon
always tells her to forget about the
past and move on but she doesn't want to
that night as the two are sleeping Jon
wakes up when he hears someone outside
he grabs a weapon and slowly opens the
door only to see his best friend Madison
and a bunch of other armed people there
and before he can say anything the
strange people apprehend him and take
him away shortly after Jon is taken to a
secluded place where the leader of the
group Sheila introduces herself she
reveals that her people are a resistant
cult who are adamant on driving about
the new world scumbags here we get to
know that a minority of the Savage lands
have become tired of being treated as
Animals by the new londoners hence they
want to put an end to it all and since
John works for the props Department he's
in charge of loading the fake guns
Sheila wants him to load the guns with
real bullets so that they can Massacre
the next batch of new londoners scared
John says that he can't do it but Sheila
warns that if he doesn't he and his
mother will be hunted down elsewhere
Bernard is still disoriented and
confused by the Visions he saw earlier
that day hence to relax himself he takes
his eye chip out for a while but as soon
as he does so the director of New London
Ed calls him to his office there he
tells Bernard that he is unfit to be an
alpha plus because he is not assertive
and demanding enough he also reprimands
Bernard for acting private and suggests
he take a vacation to the Savage lands
to clear his mind that evening a
slightly upset Bernard runs into lanina
and shares everything that transpired
with him that day he also reveals that
he has started experiencing feelings
like loneliness and that is why he is
being sent to this Savage lands lanina
empathizes with him and decides to help
him out she agrees to go to the Savage
lands together with him the next morning
they board a rocket which takes them to
their destination in less than 12
minutes take that Bezos when they reach
their hotel the receptionist briefs them
about the different tours and
attractions that they can partake in
Savage lands in particular lanina is
taken aback by the strange Customs here
like getting pregnant driving Vehicles
fighting with each other and even taming
animals after this they board a tour bus
and spectate different Savage events
which are incomprehensible in New London
like the push and pull at a department
store marriage and faith in God on the
other hand a reluctant John is forced to
load the real bullets into the gun
fearing that the cult members will go
after his mother even his best friend
Madison starts ordering him around a
while later the last show of the day the
house of monogamy commences and all the
new londoners including Bernard and
lanina are seated in the audience for a
while things go as usual but when it's
time for the prop gun to fire a real
bullet comes out and kills a person the
audience still thinks it's part of the
show so they watch an excitement but
soon some cult members get up from their
seats and start shooting at everyone
they kill many new londoners and seeing
this lanina finally realizes that
something is wrong she quickly grabs
Bernard and runs away from the place
while barely avoiding the gunshots but
unfortunately just as they reach a bit
further she realizes that Bernard has
been shot in the chest and that he is
losing Consciousness somehow she drags
him to a nearby residence and starts
crying and to make matters worse the
cult members arrive outside looking for
them John spots them and gets ready to
alert the other cult members but when he
sees the innocent couple he surprisingly
changes his mind and decides to help
them shortly after Jon brings the couple
to his house where his kind mother Linda
tries her best to save Bernard she takes
the bullet out from his body and gets
ready to stitch his wounds but just then
John's friend Madison arrives outside
she has come looking for the final two
new londoners because apparently someone
saw them fleeing in the store Direction
Jon quickly hides them in the attic and
welcomes Madison inside he promises her
that he doesn't know about the new
londoners but Madison is skeptical she
starts searching around the house and
suddenly Bernard gains Consciousness and
starts wailing in pain enraged that she
has been lied to she points her gun at
Jon but fortunately Linda stabs her from
behind and kills her madison sucked
anyway after this all four of them get
in John's car and leave the house while
the cult members close in along the way
they notice that the bus in which the
new londoners arrive has been totally
destroyed Bernard who has started
feeling a bit better now starts blaming
the savages for everything but lanina
inserts that they are alive because of
them meanwhile we learned that Jon's
mother Linda was also an inhabitant of
New London and that she had come to the
Savage lands three decades back with her
love interest but after she became
pregnant she decided to stay in Savage
lands for her son as it is illegal to
have a child in New London her husband
left with the promise of coming back but
he never did we also learned that there
is an electromagnetic barrier which
surrounds the Savage lands if a Savage
tries Crossing it he or she is
immediately burnt to death but a
resident of New London like Linda can
bypass it effortlessly however her son
John who was born into the shopping
requires assistance from an alpha plus
like Bernard this is why she helped the
new londoners hoping that she and John
can return back to their home after a
while the group reaches the border which
unfortunately is being checked by the
cult members hence Linda guides everyone
to a nearby Jungle which also has a way
across the barrier they travel on foot
and are almost there but suddenly a
bunch of armed cult soldiers start
shooting at them Bernard and lanina
quickly crossed the barrier and when a
cult Soldier tries following them he is
burnt to ashes what an idiot seeing this
Jon hesitates to go giving the cult
soldiers ample time to take a shot
fortunately Linda pushes him over the
line and Jon gets out of the Savage
lands without being burnt this is
possible because both his parents are
new londoners with this all of them
escape the place while the cruel occult
leader Sheila stares at them
unfortunately when they board the rocket
Jon realizes that his mother got shot
while trying to protect them as she
tells them to watch out and take care
she slowly succumbs to her injuries in
the next scene the group is returned to
New London and using the highly Advanced
Medical Services Bernard becomes
completely healed however lanina feels
strange and is ridden with guilt and
sadness even the Soma cannot help her it
appears as if she has started garnering
feelings something which is not possible
in New London on the other hand John has
been kept confined in a room where he
keeps screaming about his mother and
Mustafa Monde the most intelligent
person in all the land observe him
closely and deduce that the Savages are
extremely weak when it comes to dealing
with someone's demise while Ed wants him
to suffer Monde is empathetic and
decides to let him integrate into New
London for his heroics at last she lets
him out of the room and Jon glances at
the advanced City for the first time the
next morning the integration of Jon
begins addend Mustafa Monde assigned
Bernard with the task as he knows the
Savage personally however things don't
quite go as planned John is scared of
even the basic amenities like the
elevator the tall skyscrapers and even
the Soma he rejects all of them and just
remains silent after a while a
technician approaches him to measure his
eyeballs for the implementation of the
Indira ship surprisingly he realizes
that Jon has a very rare eyeball which
only an alpha exotic person has Alpha
Exotics are the rarest and the best of
all inhabitants and only 0.01 percent of
new londoners have ever been found as
such despite this Revelation Jon refuses
to have the implant and while Bernard is
away he sneaks out of the room he then
Ventures into the main hall where all
the people are amused to see a Savage
they call him names and stare at him
until Jon freaks out and runs away he
then heads into the Epsilon section
where all of the opinionless people are
having breakfast seeing John's scared
the Epsilon with feelings from earlier
see Jack 60 who for some reason gets to
use his gamer tag as his name invites
him to his table and offers him his
dinner surprisingly John loves it and
the two start bonding however their
interaction is cut short when the
director Ed barges into the room and
disperses all the epsilons he then
convinces Jon to come along with him
claiming that he can take him to a
better place where he truly belongs Jon
who is scared and confused agrees on the
other hand Bernard is also looking for
Jon and he decides to stop by Ed's
office for a quick chat strangely on the
table he finds Ed's eye chip which
implies that he has gone private since
Ed is also an alpha exotic he quickly
takes out Jon's eye chip from earlier
and Compares them lo and behold the two
implants match revealing that Jon's
estranged father is none other than Ed
himself he quickly heads to his fellow
Alpha plus Henry and reveals this but
the latter doesn't believe it and
instead criticizes Bernard for sneaking
into the director's office elsewhere Ed
takes John near the sea where a rocket
is waiting to take him away to his land
Jon is a bit skeptical because if the
cult leaders find him again they will
Lynch him to death but Ed reveals that
there are thousands of other cities like
the Savage lands where people have built
civilizations he knows this because he
ventured to several of them including
the Savage Lance hearing this Jon
realizes that Ed is his own father who
never came back after conceiving him he
demands answers but Ed doesn't seem to
care as a result Jon gets angry and
starts a scuffle which ends with Ed
accidentally falling off the cliff to
his death but since he had left his eye
chip in his office no one saw the
incident soon John rushes back to the
city and stumbles upon one of Watson's
pleasure parties he sees hundreds of
people dancing and gets scared but just
then the party-goers notice him they
surround Jon and get ready to have their
way with him but fortunately Bernard
arrives in the nick of time and rescues
him with this Jon finally starts
trusting Bernard and he even eats a Soma
pill given to him meanwhile after the
incident at Savage lands lanina has
started behaving strangely she is always
lost in her thoughts rarely goes out
with her friends behaves rudely
sometimes and even try tries to keep
herself from taking the Soma pills in
one instance she has some fun with the
alpha plus Henry but dominates him as if
she is the alpha let's go on the other
hand Mustafa Mont tells Bernard that
their director Ed accidentally fell to
his death Bernard obviously doesn't
believe it and instead reveals that he
was actually John's father surprisingly
Mond already knew of this she mentions
that this is why they have to integrate
Jon into their society as soon as
possible because it is the least he
deserves Bernard agrees and before
leaving he promises to handle the
situation well to start with he takes
John to the Children's Learning Center
where a bunch of kids are now learning
how to play a game expectedly Jon is not
interested but still he sits around as
the kids don't stare and judge him after
this Bernard takes him to the pleasure
party designer Watson's place he
introduces the two but surprisingly
Watson already knows about the Savage in
fact she is very aroused by him because
of last night's encounter where he
attracted a lot of people she wants to
have fun with the Savage but Bernard
tells her that Jon is very very
emotional and that's why it wouldn't be
a good idea instead he promises to bring
him along to that evening's pleasure
party elsewhere lanina goes to play
tennis with her best friend Franny in
New London people play only for fun and
not competitiveness or prizes however
lanina who has completely changed her
behavior humiliates her friend before
walking out of there she then reaches
her room and eats several Soma pills to
calm herself down at night the pleasure
party commences and Bernard takes Jon
there he plans to teach in the ways of
interacting with others but before that
A desperate Watson arrives and takes Jon
away to her cabin wasting no time the
two immediately have fun meanwhile
Bernard who is alone chats to a few beta
inhabitants about his Savage friend as
the people become intrigued Bernard also
starts boasting about the time when he
barely escaped out of the Savage lands
but just then the Arrogant Henry who has
also become the new director arrives and
humiliates him in front of everyone a
reinvigorated John also arrives at the
scene and overhears everything seeing
his only friend getting bullied he comes
angry and convinces Bernard to take
action he even teaches him how to punch
someone as apparently the people of New
London don't even know how to throw a
fist after a bit of practice the two
head back to the club and see Henry
dancing with lanina enraged Bernard
swings his hand and punches Henry hard
in the face shocking everyone the
Epsilon cjac 60 who is also present
Witnesses the commotion and smiles just
like my days in the fortnite lobby it
appears as if he also wants to dance to
be free and to punch people in the final
scene Bernard meets lanina in a private
room and the two share how they have
been feeling different as of late when
they get close and hold hands The Savage
John is having the time of his life
dancing with several people
to see what happens next watch the
second part in series recapped